which we're trying to pass in washington
aims to do that it's a pro-family
pro-worker agenda this important package
that will move us forward in terms of
america's working families well it's
still bigger than anything we have ever
done in in in terms of addressing the
needs of america's working families
but it turns out all that was just lip
service of course tucked inside the
so-called build back better bill
is an insidious provision that would
flood the country with cheap foreign
labor
how well my next guest uncovered
sections in the bill that would
essentially allow
unlimited numbers of green cards to be
issued to foreign workers especially in
the tech industry tennessee senator bill
haggerty joins me now senator
what does this provision or this
language mean
for those americans who want to work in
industries such as tech
well laura they hid this provision in a
2500 page bill certainly they haven't
been touting it but what it does to the
american worker is set them back for a
generation to come
while big tech billionaires are smiling
all the way to the bank it gives a
10-year hiatus
on caps on green cards basically
unlimited green cards which means
permanent residence for foreign workers
right here in america these big tech
companies can hire as many foreign
workers as they want they don't have to
worry about discriminating against
american workers they can do it all day
long just last week facebook actually
had to settle a multi-million dollar
suit for discriminating against american
workers in favor of foreign workers this
provision basically allows that to
happen all day long
now it wasn't long ago senator i think
that bernie sanders opposed
these types of policies watch the middle
class in this country continues to
shrink wages are going down i don't know
why we need millions
of people to be coming into this country
as guest workers who will work for lower
wages than american workers and drive
wages down even lower than they are
right now
senator hagerty
what the heck happened to senator
sanders he's completely abandoned
american workers here if this language
is allowed to stay in this legislation
it's hard to believe i mean i wrote him
on friday to let him know that this was
in the bill perhaps he didn't know i
really am surprised to find myself
agreeing on anything with bernie sanders
but in this case
if he indeed wants to protect the
american worker we're on the same page i
don't know where he'll come out on this
but this bill has so many other problems
in and i'm certain
the big issue here
is that we're going to harm american
workers and we're going to take away the
opportunity for our kids i was just in
memphis laura meeting with leaders there
community leaders encouraging them to
get young people to focus on stem
education from middle school and high
school areas you know this is going to
be something i think that we've got to
focus on to make a real opportunity for
our youth
we've got new high-tech jobs coming into
tennessee i want those kids ready for
those jobs the last thing we want
is for those jobs to be given to foreign
workers and much worse than what bernie
sanders was talking about in the clip he
was talking about guest workers who
would come for a temporary period
these are permanent residency status
employment arrangements here and they
would allow this for a decade again this
will knock out opportunity for a
generation to come well you have that
and then you have millions of people
flooding across our southern border who
again if the democrats have their way
will be able to stay and work in some
capacity most of them in entry-level
jobs but that's going to hurt the lower
income people
then the middle income to upper middle
income are going to be hurt from the
visa so american citizens are getting it
every which way from the democrats
policies and i'm just going to say this
again senator aoc the squad sanders
all these so-called republicans who are
standing by silent why are you the only
ones speaking out about this where
where's where are all the other senators
i mean honestly where are they tonight
we we've been digging in deep on this i
intend to expose this to my colleagues
and i hope many other republican
senators will step up and push back on
this just like i plan to do yeah i hope
so because we're going to be we're going
to be naming names if they don't senator
hagerty thank you for bringing this to
our attention what a scandal